bienvenue à bord de la banque j'aurais
jamais imaginé un jour être sur un
voilier comme celui ci pourquoi la
banque parce que c'est toujours la
banque qui gagne voilà pourquoi tricher
ne fait pas partie de nos méthodes
j'ai compris votre bilan il ya autre
chose à comprendre n'ont rien d'autre à
comprendre études c'est moi qui suis
passé à côté mais je te remercie encore
une fois et comme je suis réputé pour
être généreux envers les gens qui me
veulent du bien nous avons créé dit et
en compte de la somme que tu as perdu en
changer c'est pas trop quoi dire merci à
vostu verra je te mets une petite
rallonge pour les ennuis quant à causer
tu devrais pouvoir aller au bout de tes
études voilà deux petites affaire se
termine ici sauf si tu as le désir de
peut-être rester dans le coin pour te
confronter au vrai business
un salaires à sept chiffres les 18
premiers mois un salaire à huit chiffres
les trois premières années
qu'est ce que t'en dit direct sur new
york où tu restes avec moi
vous croyez quoi